[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
and broadcast on first of June I'm James
Heal The Spectators political
correspondent and your host for this
week's episode
coming up on the program
is Rishi turning red Kate Andrews has
written about the prime minister's new
socialist transformation for the cover
piece this week she joins me on the show
alongside Sebastian Payne the director
of the center right think tank onward
it's been a week of blob on blob
fighting between the cabinet office and
the covert inquiry but is there a
cultural problem within the Civil
Service joining me to discuss is
quentinlets
there's trouble in Spain as prime
minister Pedro Sanchez has called for a
snap general election in a bid to save
his Premiership following a Triumph for
the opposition and the local elections
last week can he regain control and what
has been so controversial about the day
selected to go to the polls
I'm joined by Esperanza Aguirre almost
all of our British fears will be
familiar with the Phillips Schofield
Saga over the past two weeks a data mitv
presenter who dramatically resigned
after nearly 40 years of working in
television following a sex scandal at
work but why are Brits so obsessed with
salacious stories
Douglas Murray thinks there's bigger
fish to fry he'll be joining me on the
show to discuss his article and finally
when Victorian School Masters and
Oxbridge educated gentleman were taming
football and codifying cricket games
that dated back to the Pagan era clung
on in isolated pockets of rural Britain
do any of them still exist today Harry
Pearson has written a book on the weird
and wonderful world of focusboard from
cheese rolling to bottle kicking he
Reveals All on the show
before we get going thanks to our
brilliant sponsors Canada wealth
management for supporting the show can
accord or experienced wealth planners
and investment managers who offer
unwavered support in challenging times
visit canadawealth.com for more
information
if you enjoy spectacular TV then do
subscribe to our YouTube channel just
click the Subscribe button at the bottom
of this video tap the Bell icon so you
never miss another episode
first up Kate Andrews has written the
cover piece for this week's magazine
about Rishi sunak's political makeover
the prime minister is Shifting to the
left of the political Spectrum with
price controls and high taxes she says
but does he really believe in his
policies Kate joins me now with
Sebastian Payne director of the center
right think tank onward
Kate you write in this week's magazine
about Rishi sunax government and how he
says he wants to cut the side of the
state but actually it's growing over
bigger tell us about this argument so
just one year and we look at the end of
rishisi next time in the treasury as
Chancellor it was very clear where he
stood philosophically and on public
policy this was a fiscal Hawk he was
somebody who was terrified that the UK
was borrowing and spending so much money
he was one of the first politicians in
the UK to predict the inflation crisis
he understood the consequences of all
this
um he hated the idea of giving Public
Services more money without reform
um you know a very classic conservative
in many ways and I I think in many ways
did own that that claim to thatcherism
perhaps in a slightly more modern more
nuanced context
um now we go forward a year and Rishi
sunak is in charge she can no longer
claim that another prime minister is
forcing him to spend money and we look
at what he's doing and where he has been
consistent is always talking about
trade-offs he does not pretend that you
can borrow and spend as you'd like and
cut taxes and the public finances will
be fine he does believe things need to
be costed he's consisted on that but
look at the choices he's making he's
going for more spending a higher tax
rate than there even was under Boris
Johnson higher tax burden approaching
about 78 years he's somebody who is
increasing bloating the size of the
state adding to the public services
rather than looking at tax cuts rather
than looking at areas for efficiency and
I think we need to talk about that
because the narrative suggests one thing
and the action suggests quite another
and I think those actions suggest that
we are certainly in a high tax High
spend Tory era and if anyone was going
to change that apart from Liz truss's
attempt
it might have been in a in a more in a
more stable more pragmatic way Rishi
sunac but we're not seeing it so is that
fair criticism well I think obviously
conservatism by its definition is a kind
of adaptable Creed it's for the time the
it serves and in case peace you refer
back to the maids lecture which is the
nearest thing to an O text of what Rishi
sunak stands for in terms of his
intellect actual Outlook but clearly
that was when he was translating he's
now prime minister and all those things
you said he's facing are completely true
but you're also these are not
necessarily his fault you know you have
got the Ukraine war the backlogs from
covid the worldwide inflation crisis the
energy security problem and so you're
right that there are trade-offs but I
think when you look at the decisions the
prime minister is making he is favoring
the kind of pragmatism you've seen from
many conservative Prime Ministers you
mentioned in the in the piece of the
magazine this week Kate the windfall tax
and say this is an example of how he's
moving away from that original Vision
you know Win 4 tax have been used
several times by conservative Prime
Ministers when the times need them
George Osborne propoted one after the
financial crisis Margaret Thatcher did
two win four taxes on the banks again to
try and get that sense of fairness
because if you're not doing that the
question is what is the alternative and
I think the question I'd say to you is
that if you look at what Mr sunac is
doing we'd all like tax cuts I think no
one's disagreeing with that and I think
we probably will get some tax cuts
before the general action but it's what
would you like to see now I think the
most sympathetic argument to Rishi sunak
is that he's had to deal with a lot of
external factors which you just listed
out there and he has to clean up clean
up a lot of other people's economic
messiness uh Boris Johnson Liz trusts to
name a few people he has been put in
really difficult circumstances that is
the argument he's always made right when
he was hiking corporation tax in the
March budget for 2021
um you know when he's been growing the
size of the state doing all of these
handouts he's always been saying I'm
forced to do it the question I'm asking
this week is well you're in charge now
and can we really claim everything
that's happening is something that
you're being forced to do two examples I
use are the child care handout to middle
class families 33 hours a week and and
also if we look at what's going to
happen to the welfare bill under the new
projections from this last budget which
was Jeremy Hunt overseen by Rishi sunak
it's increasing by 16 over the next four
years it's going to go up to 330 billion
pounds and I see that as a political
choice I see that as a decision not to
reform the child care sector a decision
not to reform welfare a decision to
spend more money on the windfall tax I
think there's a narrative here too which
we see a bit with corporation tax as
well which is that Rishi CNAC is always
Keen to say to show that he's so
pro-business
so long as he gets along with business
and then when he wants them to do
something which is usually to invest
that looming thread of attacks is is
hovering over them and eventually it
comes in I don't think that's even how
necessarily but she sunak would describe
the brand of conservatism that he signs
up to but that is what we're getting
um and the argument I would I would use
around winful taxes is okay other people
have implemented them we are seeing real
consequences they are always a bad idea
um we we have major energy companies
that are now get firing hundreds of
people we're seeing them take their
money to other countries we're seeing
hundreds of millions of pounds leaving
this country when it could be invested
in cleaner and Greener energy here the
real consequences to all of this and I I
think Rishi sunak knows this I think
he's possibly one of the most
economically literate Prime Ministers
we've ever had and uh you know I think
he's well aware of these arguments he
can see the consequences he's in charge
now he can change the direction but I
think a lot of this is about is about
choices as you say and you can just do
all those things and I think if you take
a particular view of conservative to
critique them you can say well actually
no they're not that accepted but then
the question is what is the alternative
to these things the reason we see that
did the win four tax was because we had
a very cute problem with energy bills
there and if you don't do that win four
tax where are you going to get the money
to pay for that or are you going to pass
those bills on to Consumers that has
political consequence I mean the
government will be spectacularly
unpopular if you did that with child
care again that's an example of trying
to deal with a problem with the labor
market and trying to help mothers who
want to get back into the workplace do
so after that I think well I agree with
you Kate though is about the ambition of
reform within public service that at the
moment is not quite enough ambition to
look at these things if you think about
when the conservatives came back into
power in 2010 who had plans for
Universal Credit which I think is one of
the great success stories of the past 13
years but where's the ambition for that
now you're right that there still needs
to be this push to look at people who
are not active within the workplace the
NHS uh something I know you love right
now a lot that is something that does
need to have a look at in terms of what
is structure of it and where it's going
in the future but again it's something
that's politically not you can't be
touched at the moment so ultimately I
think when you look at what this is
actually doing you're right he does know
that in his ideal dream world this is
not the kind of approach he'd be doing
but he's having to deal with the
circumstance he's got now and if you
weren't doing those things again it's in
this case what is the alternative so if
you were to try and cut the tax burden
you're right it is obviously the highest
I think it's seven decades but by oecd
standards the individual taxes are not
actually that high then where's that
money go from where's it going to come
to and I think a lot of this speaks to
the fact with almost the end of a
political cycle that we've got a general
election next year in May or October
depending on who you listen to in
Westminster and almost everything that's
being talked about thought about the
government is through the election lens
and I think what I think you should be
looking at as well is what actual
reforms can you get done to make things
better before then look ahead to that
next election I want to ask you both
what are the kind of key differences
philosophically and pragmatically
between how they approach the state
because as you say Kate I mean to be
sort of very kind of interventions model
for the state are there going to be any
kind of you know dividing lines between
the two and it's a clear blue water or
is it simply now about sort of
technocracy and kind of functionary like
we saw in the 60s and 70s in the sort of
post-war consensus
um well look there are definitely key
differences between labor and the Tories
right now I think the difficulty is
separating the philosophy behind it and
that is really really worrying so you
have Kia stammer arguing that we should
stop new production of oil in the North
Sea
um that argument is made possible
because of things like an effective 75
tax rate on those energy companies
brought in by Rishi CNAC you have Labor
hinting at the idea that they would do
an outright smoking ban for younger
Generations that is made possible by all
of the Tory parties Nanny State
interventions and the difficulty for the
Tories if they were to find themselves
out of power is that you they would find
themselves in a position where they
would disagree with the policy but when
you broke it down they would struggle to
disagree with with the the fundamental
pillars that it was based on I mean look
at something like the energy price
guarantee price controls which have been
in the news this week I don't think
number 10 is implementing mandatory
price controls on supermarkets but how
did they end up in a situation where
those words were even being bandied
about
um you know this is this is like
economic illiteracy 101.
um and and the fact that that's
happening is I think partially because
the Tory party has been playing with
price controls and you know so if you
keep saying well what could they do
differently you know I think that kind
of argument is brought up all the time
and I have always given the chancellor
quite a lot of sympathy on this point
because he truly found himself in a
unique position but if you're arguing
that you need the windfall tax to
subsidize households for their energy
costs don't expand the energy price
guarantee which Jeremy Hunt did under
Rishi sunak don't expand that huge
middle class subsidy for so many people
who don't need it go back to that
targeted approach I I think this idea
that you can simply say external forces
have made it this way would actually be
to underplay so much of the credibility
that Rishi sunak has built up over the
past few years it would be to underplay
him as a politician I think it's quite
clear he can do more the issue of course
is is that there isn't a lot of time to
do it because as you say Seb you know an
election is not that far away I think
the Philosopher's difference is that I
still think Rishi Suma first of all
believes in Market solutions for things
I'm not sure you see necessarily from
Kia style because if you take the
naughty oil announcement this week you
know the only as as people have said if
you do that that's going to make the UK
more of aligned on imports from overseas
and that's something that has big energy
security consequences for the UK and I
think we should see now it's got a clear
dividing line there in terms of how he's
looking at by again this kind of
pragmatic approach that I still think is
focused on what he's doing on looking
for Market Solutions where you can but
it's not unrestrained Market Solutions
and I don't think that you know the
broad base of conservatism is not
necessarily just about having a state
that is absent it is about out an active
State and you know to going back what I
said earlier the person who's often held
up as the most purest prime minister in
terms of free market economics was
Margaret Thatcher who introduced the
development corporations who shied away
from nationalizing the railways you know
and who bailed out ICL the big British
computer company in the 1980s she was
pragmatic in the same way Richie sunak
is pragmatic and it's no coincidence
that Nigel Lawson obviously her great
Chancellor endorsed Mr sunak in the
leadership contest because of that focus
on sound finances but I think when you
come to the next election you know Kia
storm is clearly being pulled in One Way
by Labor's activist base that's the only
reason I could see you would make that
North Sea oil announcement because you
they're worried about the green party
and that kind of contingent that's got
very radical views on climate change but
I think what you will see is indications
because there's not much time left to
make a much more free market case for
this government but I think there will
be something on the tax burden there
will be more ambition on informing
Public Services if I'm the one don't
forget this is soon that's been prime
minister about six months now and as you
said Kate has a lot of fiscal medicine
to clean up from several previous Prime
Ministers he's making Headway on that
the question though he's going to
focused on is come the Autumn when
hopefully the economy is in a better
place inflation is coming down and
there's a bit more political space to
play with how to use that and that will
actually test your philosophy at that
point what do you do are you doing
things with the election or are you
looking at more ambition I don't think
we're running the risk of having an
absent State that's not the problem
right now you know it there's a lot of
talk of the 1970s this week and Mel
astride actually had to go on the
airwaves and you know responding to
criticisms about price control say we're
not heading towards the 1970s I mean
that a Tory party has to make that clear
shows the situation we're in and he's
right that there are fundamental
differences the tax burden is higher
than it was in the 70s it's worse than
the 70s the state is double the size so
I don't think the fear right now is that
we're going to some kind of absent kind
of government the the fear right now is
that that it is so big so overbearing
and it is a Tory government and by the
way I just make very clear successive
Tory governments that have allowed this
to happen and I I fear Rishi c-neck
might fall into the same trouble as
Boris Johnson did as Theresa May did
where they take their eye off the ball
on this and they discover that certain
kinds of public policy have happened to
them and they find themselves in a
position where it's actually very
difficult for them to make the case for
a leaner more effective State because
they're the ones that muddied it in the
first place I think the point on price
control shows as well as sort of
discipline because I think there's
absolutely no way a conservative
government is going to introduce price
controls I think you've had some
overzealous briefing from a junior spad
that makes it to a Sunday newspaper and
of course you said Mouse ride came out
and slammed that right down because that
is just not going to happen but I think
you have got a point about your eye on
the ball there Kate that you're saying
you've got to think what are your
instincts what are you trying to aim
towards if you go back and said to the
maze lecture I still think miss you
sooner believes that that is what he is
trying to get her but it's how and where
you adapt that to these particular
circumstances a debate that's going to
carry on thank you very much for joining
us
are you happy in your work well that's
certainly not a question I get asked
very regularly but in the Civil Service
Naval gazing is an annual routine
sketchwriter Quentin lets at the Times
writes for this week's magazine that
feedback forms and people surveys have
turned the blob into a bureaucratic
machine incapable of getting work done
but is he right he's with me now to
discuss
now Quentin you write in this week's
magazine about the Civil Service people
survey uh tell us what inspired you to
write about this well there was a select
committee uh in which the uh the Chief
Operating Officer of the Civil Service
Alex Chisholm I almost called him sir
Alex was giving evidence about this
thing along with two other top mandarins
this is the people survey where they
basically the Civil Service goes to 350
000 civil servants and does to them what
happens in cheap restaurants when
someone comes along and says everything
all right with your meal and uh this is
the Civil Service saying to its
employees is there anything you want to
complain about and guess what they they
do they do want to complain about and
the main thing they want to complain
about is pay yeah so they say
um we we think we're being worked too
hard and we're not being paid enough
and uh therefore there is now then
evidence for uh for pay Rises It's a
Wonderful Circle
you've been covering Westminster now for
about 30 odd years how was this sorry to
remind you how was the quality of
Mandarin of Humphrey changed in that
time well it was not so
subpar
um the civil servants of old tended not
to be seen very much and didn't do
nearly as many select committees
and therefore we had an ideal they were
these great figures in Elysium who were
able
and now that we can see them we realize
that anything but able and they're
frightful wafflers and Chisholm uh has
he had a wonderful voice very deep voice
downside he went to inside went to
Oxford he's all the business but he
talks seamless balls if we can say that
and um really it just comes out of him
um like a a long stream of sausage and
uh they was with with two other people
doing the same next to him must have
been quite a tough experience for you
these these select communities become
like this but going back to your
question about the civil servants I
think
I suspect that they have always probably
been not as good as we we hoped or we
imagined
but it's quite good if you're not very
good
to keep quiet about it and not to be
seen on Parade so my advice to mandarins
is you know if you're asked to do a
select committee say no
and you've had a bit of a run-in with
Alexis when you're writing this week
really I had a run-in with his meter
um I wrote about him before in the times
and uh I I took the rise slightly and uh
um the mother Chisholm wrote In from I
think Hampshire
um a steaming missive arrived from a
handwritten in ink and uh almost
levitating off the desk she was so angry
with me and I loved it I thought she was
terrific and she put me for me in my
Pace she's obviously um you know a
proper old dragon and uh and I I I've
fallen in love with Mr Chisholm now but
um you know her son is still worthy of a
certain amount of satire and what do you
think about each sort of talk about the
Civil Service being a sort of conspiracy
about the side of a blob do you think
that they're capable enough to mount a
coup against the government well they
are quite good the one thing they're
good at
taking tax
it's funny when it comes to actually
for them
um or giving them the money to pay pay
themselves they are quite good and so
they do this people survey
um 350 000 people I think there's
something like 17 000 business units in
the Civil Service get this and uh across
100 departments and uh it's quite a big
operation it obviously has a team of
people who are needed I must say
listening to that select committee do
you remember the bird and Fortune
sketches on the Brendan show it was very
like that where the the
self-justifications and about how
important it all was about how much hard
work it was
and not only do they have the survey
they also had surveys of the survey and
they have benchmarking and they have
best practice and uh and there's also an
international element where the oecd is
involved and so that presumably
necessitates foreign fact-finding trips
uh over weekends in glorious places like
Strasbourg and uh sunnier climbs but the
the
I don't know I mean it's a rude question
James but God have you ever mined your
belly button for fluff uh I sometimes do
it uh and it you know you can find
things it's quite a Moorish activity you
look there and you say oh that's
interesting you find bits of old lunch
and the more you do it the more you want
to do it and it becomes a terrible time
waster and this is basically what this
people survey is it's a terrible time
wasting belly button fluff
um mining operation I think it was Peter
Hennessy coined the phrase that is often
in Whitehall it's not so much about
evidence-based policy making as
policy-based evidence making where you
get into this kind of endless cycle of
stuff Peter would have loved this but of
course Peter was the uh tutor of Simon
case who is the head of the Civil
Service and why on Earth at a time when
our tax rates are shooting up when our
national debt is shooting up what we're
doing wasting time and money on this I
don't know we and it was not disclosed
how much this cost but one dreads to
think uh and um they were asked how
often people looked at these dashboards
they have dashboards of course for the
um this this people survey and 17 000
civil servants a day look at this thing
but you know this survey wouldn't you
like to be asked how you're feeling at
work
not wildly uh I've never been in all
let's see as you mentioned of being a
hack I've never been asked I don't think
I can't remember ever being asked are
you happy
and um what a waste of time let's just
get on with the job
and my final question Quentin I mean
you've been covering Whitehall for 30 or
two years or so I'm sure there'll be
some aspiring mandarins watching this at
home young civil servants what kind of
tips would you give them on in a game
for them to be in a select commission
you can't get out of it what are the
best ways to waffle and prevaricate that
you've seen from your many years
watching these things you've got very
short answers very short answers yes or
no and then the MP hasn't had time to
think up next it's the same at Prime
Minister's questions brevity is all
brevity is completely confounding
throughs them and also that way you
you'll get out of it quicker because
they'll run out of questions well there
we are for those watching at home thank
you Quentin
prime minister Pedro Sanchez is just
called a snap election in Spain after a
crushing defeat in Regional polls as the
right wing rises in Spain can the Prime
Minister click onto his post with me now
is the former Minister and journalist
Esperanza Aguirre
and we took up a lot about Italy what's
going on with the new prime minister
there we've talked about the ruptures in
France but tell us what's happening in
the Spanish situation with an election
coming up
well as you know we've recently last
week we had a municipal and Regional
elections and in that elections uh the
the popular party which is center right
had a big success
and there was also a party uh far more
to the right that had also a great
result the Socialist Party who's
governing with the Communists the
independentists and the former
terrorists which are in his lists and
have not say they they they've they are
sorry for the for the crimes they had
has had a failure enormous failure
especially the Communists they are not
no more in the more important Regional
governments and now the the president of
the government the prime minister you
should say the elections took place on a
Sunday on Monday he decided to call a
general election for the 23rd of July
which means we're going to vote at 40 or
more degrees Centigrades because July is
here very very hot month especially in
the south of Spain
even in Andalucia which is the South the
southern region of Spain it is forbidden
to call elections in July or August but
not general elections that's a national
thing is there a bit of an upset about
this a kind of outcry we are upset
because we think uh it is very difficult
to have a vote in Spain on the 23rd of
July because the half of Spanish people
on a no vacation and the the male vote
is very difficult here but he's in a he
he has done it and he can do it because
he's the Prime Minister and he has
dissolved the Cortes generalis and he
had a call he has called a general
election but that's not the important
thing the important thing is that he has
what we have called
Frankenstein government which means it
was not a socialist party which is
similar to labor labor moderate labor it
is the only government in in Europe
which is with the Communists in the in
the government that have done a very
incredible things uh and and the Prime
Minister has done everything that the
Communists wanted and how much trouble
do you think Pedro Sanchez is in well I
don't think he's in the trouble he's
said he all he wanted is to go to a
village in Almeria in the south of Spain
and rest so we hope in August he could
do that and we are going to have the
government and what we have said get
back every uh stupid laws that this man
has approved with the Frankenstein
majority a loss of Europe seems to be
heading to the right is this a trend
which Spain is following
well we we have been trending to the
left for the last five years this is the
first time we we are in the right but
that it has been a local and Regional
election so I hope in the general
election our party my party the popular
party who has been uh who who comes
every every time we have to arrange the
economy with Mr adnar first and then Mr
rahoy and then the Socialists come they
spend all the money of the contributors
and we have to come to arrange the the
political and economic matters and how
relevant is the issue of catalonian
separatism
it's very relevant because Catalunya is
not Scotland
Scotland has been independent for many
years and you are a United Kingdom you
have four nations in our Constitution
which was voted in Catalunya for
92 percent of the people uh our
constitution says Spain's is a an only
it's only one nation
so if you want to be separatist which
The Basque did once you have to to
follow the rules the rule of law is
important in England that's why I admire
so much the British people and here the
rule of law said if you want to separate
from Spain you have to come to the
National Parliament you have to be voted
there and then you have a national
referendum no they did a local
referendum and and they decided to be
separate what I told you the the leader
of the Basque nationalists came to the
National Party he did not have the
majority it's only the overall majority
it's not a qualified majority overall
majority did not have it and he came
back because he wanted to go to be like
Puerto Rico
a free free Associated state or
something like that with Puerto Rico's
we do not just we'll do the United
States
um Esperanto what do you make of the
current caliber of politicians in Spain
what would we say there's there's all in
the in the vineyard of the lord we have
very good politicians in both sides and
we have very bad politicians in both
sides too
um
populism that's what you're asking
really no there's populism in the in the
Communist Party Mr Mr Iglesias which
once because it has been very important
the results in the region of Madrid Mr
Iglesias the leader former leader of the
podemos party which is the Communist
Party in Spain from his point of view is
a good politician from my point of view
he is a good politician but his ideas
are contrary to mine and on the right
there are also populists is Voxer
populist party which is on the far right
well we we popular party agree with Vox
in the three most important things the
unity of Spain the defending defending
property and defending Liberty in other
things we are not completely agree with
them I do not agree in disappearing the
regional government because I have been
I have been in the national government
in the National Senate I was the
president of the Senate and also I have
been president of the regional
government of Madrid and I can tell you
I would not have been able to do what I
did and what I think is very good for
Madrid
if I had to wait for the Socialist prime
minister we had at the time to do the
things I was free in my regional laws to
do what I thought it was the best for
the motherlands and just finally Vox
might form a coalition government what
are they likely to ask for in government
I think they are going to ask to De
rogar take out the laws that were very
very bad for Spain and the Socialist
Franken state government has just
approved I think they're going to ask
that and we will be we will agree in
most of them for example what they call
the law of the democratic Memoir which
means you cannot be you cannot have the
freedom of speech or the freedom of
writing if you think that for example
Franco did something
good no you can't do that it would be a
crime another law the law that is called
the yes is yes we call the CSC which
means that they have made disappear the
presumption of innocence from for the 50
of population men don't have a
presumption of innocence if a woman says
that she did not want to have um sex
with him
she says that uh the the man had to
demonstrate that that is not true
instead of the other one have to prove
that her there has been a rape you
understand I don't know if I explained
this in my very very very very forgotten
English not at all it's great
um thank you for joining us on spectator
TV
thank you
hello and welcome to women balls where I
Katie will speak to today's Trailblazers
[Music]
next what is behind this strange
obsession with Philip Schofield asked
Douglas Murray in this week's magazine
is it a distraction from the bigger
problems facing Britain he's with me now
to discuss
so Douglas in this week's magazine you
write about Phillip Schofield what
inspired you to choose this topic for
your column
well obviously it is an incredibly
inspirational subject no I mean really
it was just the fact that I have been
astonished amazed that the last 10 days
of news in Britain has been so almost
completely blackout wall-to-wall Phillip
Schofield I said recently in my column I
didn't think that the British media
could get more absurd than their
obsession with uh the speeding awareness
course that the Home Secretary may have
to go on and to the extent that British
journalists from the BBC and ITV and Sky
were flown out to the G7 in Tokyo where
they used the opportunity of being in
Japan to ask Rishi sunak about suela
ratherman's speeding awareness course
and I said there I mean what gives here
this Obsession the verse media with
these minutiae stories you know I've
written about this in the magazine
before in the political field uh we had
the weeks of weeks of controversy over
Dominic Robb and the manner in which he
threw a cherry tomato into a bin a a
throw that resounded across Whitehall
apparently and terrified the Civil
Service who then said they were bullied
and then you get all the sort of uh you
know normal sort of white call covering
journalists obsessed with this how can
we get rid of the Deputy Prime Minister
then they move on to the Home Secretary
and now it seems as I always say there's
always another Circle to The Inferno it
seems that the the Packers moved on to
the this morning couch and as I say in
my column uh uh I hope it's no insult to
uh Holly Willoughby and Philip Schofield
to say this but less than one percent of
the population tuned into this morning
so what's the explanation for
wall-to-wall coverage uh about
these two really very uninteresting
people
I mean well Douglas I mean some might
say you a bit of a snob though if you're
not interested in Breakfast Television I
mean what's wrong with people being
allowed to sort of discuss the ins and
outs and these sort of people that they
live in the spot the toilet spotlighter
what's wrong with us discussing uh their
Fall From Grace
yeah no and then some people may say I'm
a bit of a snob for uh for this but
there we are
um uh I really don't mind the accession
leveled at me if it's to do with not
wanting to be completely obsessed with
uh morning television that really people
aren't interested in anyway as I say
because you can tell from the viewing
figures anyway no it is really just that
there is it is what I described as I
think a sort of um it's an odd activity
a displacement activity going on in
modern Britain that is is reflected in
other countries as well but I think is
nowhere as parochial as it is in the UK
a weird displacement activity with
getting on with other things like you
know tearing up the ITV morning
scheduling offices uh
um what are we really doing when we're
doing what is really happening when we
get these National obsessions of who
knew what when
what is it that we're doing and my my
exploration as I say in the column is
we're just distracting ourselves because
all the really big issues in our country
we completely fail to deal with I mean
you know I just watched uh I mean it's
not the biggest issue in the country but
I just watched another labor politician
failed to say that women by and large
don't have penises they get themselves
into these Middle Ages like uh
contortions on these questions of of
heresy and dogma and uh but if you get
them onto anything important ask anyone
in the cabinet or Shadow cabinet about
the about energy policy about housing
policy about immigration policy about
fiscal policy about borrowing debt
unfunded pensions liabilities inflation
you name it
what do they have to say
what do any of them have to say I mean
labor always tells us that they want to
debate no they don't because they don't
have anything to say no none of them
have anything to say about the big
issues going on and as I say I think
there is a weird displacement activity
in modern Britain which is let's play
this game of toppling person after
person politician after politician and
eventually poppling everyone off the
morning sofas uh and then we think we've
achieved something we haven't
I I mean I'm sure would be no uh I'm
sure you're interested to know Douglas
that uh MP's already said on the culture
committee that they're going to call in
itv's bosses uh next week to discuss the
issue in Parliament so uh not sure what
you'd make of that as displacement
activities as I say circle after Circle
I tell you
I mean but you're right in the column
that is a sort of singularly British
Obsession you spend a lot of time in
America and traveling elsewhere around
the world why do you think this is such
a British thing sort of focusing on the
trivial rather than the fundamental
well uh it's also there's this question
what do we do
we do it we tried to LEAP out of the EU
in 2016 and have had years of
contortions since
um the the attempt to sort of reverse
decline uh keeps running into a block or
a wall uh Liz truss said she wanted
reverse Decline and lasted about a
fortnight so the decline teams back on
the agenda
um if you ask a politician in America uh
what they want to do on the left they'll
say they want social justice and so on
and on the right they'll say they want
to build the economy
well I mean I happen to think that the
latter is more plausible and a better
answer you know Rising tide and all of
that but they they do sort of they have
a plan which is the American economy
should be going gangbusters
um what is the plan in Britain exactly
I mean do any of them know that can
Pierce Dharma give a plausible
explanation of what the country would do
under his leadership uh
can Richie soon act to that uh when it
comes to that can he actually say what
his vision of Britain is I I think the
answer is no and and that there's
something very revealing in that and and
into that void steps all of this trivia
and what I regard as being fundamentally
distracting activities
well quite and I wonder perhaps do you
think that this shows that Britain is
just simply not a serious country now
well I think we haven't been for some
time but uh I I I think that
we really
need to get out of this
this rut of thinking that if if we just
if if the media moves the latest
non-scandal Scandal along a little bit
and gets another scalp then you know we
get anywhere we don't we don't
um doesn't improve education for anyone
doesn't improve
um housing opportunities for anyone
doesn't improve the job market it
doesn't do anything really
um and so yes it it is it is a strange
it's a strange British Obsession and you
know I'm all for trivia uh in in certain
uh you know quantities but the trivia
cannot outweigh the serious stuff and as
I say I mean it's just a very bad sign
for a country that you end up being so
willing to be distracted from
distraction by Distraction
and do you write in the column um
Douglas that you think it's about sort
of misdirected anger misdirected emotion
that all this sort of stuff has
channeled into these quite trivial
matters I mean do you think that as you
say partly because we're wanting to be
distracted that we are sort of missing
uh bigger genuine scandals in this
country I know you've um written before
very in the magazine about you know the
ones on the during the troubles in
Northern Ireland I mean do you think the
sort of similar scandals are being
missed because we're simply focusing on
completely the wrong issues
well I think that's undoubtedly the case
and as I say several recent columns I've
tried to draw people's attention to this
you know as I I've said fairly often
recently what would we be doing if we
weren't doing this
uh what would the media be doing what
would government be doing if if if if if
Government didn't keep on getting
clogged up by these sorts of you know
cake gate speed gate everything's a damn
gate you know and everyone thinks it's
so original when they put gate after
anything
um and you know what would the
government be concentrating on what what
might it be achieving
um if the answer is not much more then
there's even more trouble that we're in
that I thought but but my belief is is
that we we just are horribly
misdirecting our energies and yes uh
there's there's doubt because scandals
going on there always are
um and there are scandals that are of
significance I mean you just mentioned
Northern Ireland the steak Knife
controversies come back up again I don't
think that
outside of Northern Ireland one in a
thousand households know anything about
that maybe they don't need to but it'll
probably be a more intelligent Scandal
to look at than the Gordon the gopher's
former sofa mate Scandal
um I I I I think that but as I say that
the main thing isn't isn't you know
where are the scandals that it's a very
post-watergate thing that that
journalists think that their job is to
find all the scandals that exist expose
them and then win all of the awards it's
a very it's a very sort of
post-watergate way of doing journalism
sometimes there are scandals then they
should be exposed but the whole of
Politics the whole country isn't just a
set of scandals waiting to be uncovered
you know um but but there is some
fundamental failure of the media in this
but the fundamental failure of the media
is a fundamental failure of government
it's a reflection of that which is the
the fact that government seems not to be
able to do in Britain any of the things
that we need it to do have asked it to
do and want it to do government can't
seem to do that uh it waits for for
court judgments on things before moving
ahead of anything because it seems the
government isn't in charge you know
Strasbourg still is and and on certain
matters of real immigration and and so
on they wait for decisions to be made
elsewhere to allow them to make a
decision
so yes then the Press
reflects that by also engaging in sort
of past time trivia uh I think it's a
it's it's very very sad because there
are huge issues we could be addressing
at the end of my column this week I
mentioned some of the sort of cosmic
issues we could be addressing
um but we're nowhere near that and I I
wish that it was just possible obviously
what I'm trying to do to encourage my
fellow countrymen to just rise raise
their eyes slightly
off the level of the morning television
sofa and on to the things that could
really
matter and improve things and help our
country because otherwise this this is
just going to be a perennial game of
distraction and it and it's one that I
find exhausting I suspect that most of
the people engaged find exhausting and
you know is tiring us out and wasting
our energies which need to be expended
elsewhere
we're talking if you're tired energy so
my final question Douglas uh there's now
a vacancy on this morning sofa will you
be uh throwing your hat in the ring
um no I it sound it sounds like a proper
Viper's Nest
um and um uh I don't mind getting up
early but I don't love it
um and um no I I think I think I think
I'm not in the running
um which obviously saddens me deeply
James but on the other hand leaves the
field opener for you oh I I think I've
got my place here at The Spectator with
you Douglas thank you for joining us
great pleasure and finally we don't
often discuss sport on the show so we
thought about time we did some of the
most famous sports invented rugby
Cricket Polo football you may have seen
some videos released on social media of
cheese rolling gloucestershire last week
what are these bizarre folk Sports and
how many are still looking practiced
today
joining me now is Perry Pearson who's
written a book on the weird and
wonderful world of folk Sports
I'm joined Now by Harry Pearson who's
here to discuss his new book no pie no
priest a journey through the folk Sports
of Britain uh welcome to the show for
those of our listeners who aren't
history Buffs when you say folk Sports
of Britain what does that mean exactly
um I'm talking about sports that are
actually embedded in the communities not
not kind of quirky new things like
extreme ironing and silly things like
that but things like coits and
um trap ball
um Skittles all these games that date
back in into into the sort of go back
into the distant past have been have
been banned by Monarch since the since
the 1100s at least
and I mean how many of these sports that
you cover in this book have been banned
and how many of them survived to this
day
well all of them so all the sports in
the book survive to this day but there
have been various attempts always to
suppress things I mean Skittles I think
must be the most banned game in the
history of the world there was a kind of
uh like the war it was like the War on
Drugs there was a kind of War on
Skittles that went on for 300 years it
was just about as successful as the War
on Drugs I have to say because Skittles
is still you know still a massive sport
in the west country of course why was it
so Keen to be banned um I think because
it because like All Sport it was
associated with the drinking and
gambling and then of course initially as
well it kept man away from the serious
business of practicing uh firing
longbows or shooting longbows I should
say and you say they're about Skittles
being popular in the west country I mean
were there certain sort of areas of the
country that attracted more of these
kind of folk Sports
um I think that there is certain sports
that are popular in certain places so
coits which is the you know throwing a
metal ring at a at a a metal pin called
a hob which is set in a bed of clay that
that is popular in the sort of North
riding of Yorkshire Northumberland bits
of Scotland and bits of East Anglia uh
Skittles is popular in the west country
but coins and Skittles can never
co-exist for some reason they're they're
only popular they're popular in separate
areas
um but one one never mixes with the
other that's fascinating and in terms of
these Sports I mean are any of them
particularly violent
um well someone I mean the old um the
old folk football matches of which there
used to be hundreds all across Britain
which were gradually banned over time
um the title of the book comes from the
the Hallett and bottle kicking
um which takes place in leicestershire
um it's not actually a bottle it's a
small barrel and it's a it's a game
between two Villages haliton and
maidenborn
um and originally the the local priest
gave a gave a hair pie as a kind of
prize but in 1790 he refused to give it
because he said that the hair was a
symbol of the Pagan symbol of spring and
so he refused to and so they they
protested against him and by writing on
the rectory door no pie no Priest No jog
for the glacier apparently in blood was
written so those those sports like that
as your judge from that are quite
violent I mean there was a famous uh
notorious such as they came in George in
England between the men of Suffolk and
the men of Norfolk that was played on
discommon in which nine of the parties
died
you know there's no VAR I should say to
so bottle kicking survives um and also
cheese rolling is that correct
yeah the cheese rolling at Cooper's Hill
that's a that's a that's a gay an event
that goes right back into the sort of
you know in The Mists of time again
often associated with with paganism uh
my friend Andy smart who sadly died last
month very very suddenly
um Andy took he's run but he said he'd
run he took part in it once and he said
he'd run with the bulls at Pamplona 62
times but once doing the cheese rolling
at Cooper's Hill was enough because it's
not really a hill that they roll the
cheese down it's actually a cliff that's
fascinating how many of these sort of
sports survive other than the two you
just mentioned
um well there are quite a few there are
quite a few one-off sports but then in a
sports like shinti for example in
Ireland's or Scotland which is a really
fantastic game which for some reason we
played at my primary school in Yorkshire
the weather giving a lot of Yorkshire
kids a stick and telling them to hit
things with it's a good idea I'm not
sure but I mean shinti is an absolutely
fantastic game like a kind of a rogue
version of hockey
um and I loved it as a small boy and
then I discovered later on that um one
of the great players from Newton Moore
there was a guy called Sir Thomas
McPherson before he he actually escaped
from a Nazi POW Camp on a motorbike thus
inspiring the character of Steve McQueen
in the Great Escape so once you know
that how could you not love shinti
is that your favorite sport of those
covered in this book then
I love it it just moves moves around
from end to end you know cracking Pace
everyone there will tell you that it
looks quite dangerous and they'll tell
you oh no it's not dangerous at all and
then within five seconds you can
guarantee someone will be hit in the
face enough to go off with a go off to
hospital for stitches
so if I'm writing this book about a
thousand years of British sporting
history what sort of Trends and patterns
survive to this day for instance in
terms of Engagement or you know the sort
of local civic pride in certain Sports
well I think I think there are I mean
coins is quite interesting is it funny
enough for where I grew up in in the
North Yorkshire Moors coits was really
popular and then I moved to
Northumberland and it turns out the bit
of Northumberland that I live in coits
is really popular and the the local
League when I moved here had eight teams
in it and now it's got 24 teams in it so
coins has actually got more popular
baton trap in Kent which is a game that
probably predates Cricket
um that again the the leagues there
around Canterbury they they've actually
increased the number of players around
theirs as if people really want to get
they do want to get involved in sport
and maybe a sport that they can play in
teams whether it's not too strenuous so
people can play it at all ages which I
think is one of the advantages
and is Britain a particularly sporting
Nation then obviously I think of the
kind of Victorian inventions things that
association football and rugby and
before that you know the rules of
cricket Etc but it seems from you know
meaning of this book that there's been
always a sort of at a very local level
even you know unorganized or very
organic sporting practices have always
been a part of this country's history
yeah I think they are and I think what's
interesting about that is that some
sports were codified and had us and had
a central um a central body that
organized them and so you see that with
darts I mean darts was just another Pub
sport until the 1920s when it got a
National Association
um much to the annoyance of people like
th white who felt that you know Britain
was becoming homogenized and should go
back to the old folk ways in which
everyone everyone had their own their
own type of dartboard and have their own
rules which is what happens in Skittles
I mean that's probably why Skittles has
never become as big a sport as darts
because basically if you play in
Somerset you play by completely
different rules than you do in
gloucestershire and even within
gloucestershire you play with different
rules between you know between different
towns and different villages
he was responsible for these cultures
surviving through the centuries I mean
you mentioned about the hair pie
scramble which seems a particularly
interesting uh type of sporting event in
the 18th century and the clergy's role
in that so was it often priests and
Vickers who were championing these kind
of things
the similar some of them were but a lot
they tended to Champion Sports like
Cricket that were out of doors and which
weren't were generally associated with a
kind of muscular Christianity whereas
most of the other games that they didn't
like like Skittles were associated with
public houses cricket was a way of
getting people out of public houses
generally it's why if you look in
Lancashire lots of the cricket teams in
lancash were founded by methodists and
that was you know it was a way of
getting men away from drinking and [__]
fighting another and gambling
um but whereas Skittles and things like
that tended to be associated with
drinking
and in terms of the Bands then when was
the last time any sort of Monarch really
tried to get involved in just Banning
certain Sports
well there were certain Sports I say
Skittles particularly even in even in
the 1790s they were going around in
places like Manchester saying that you
know if you were found with a Skittle
alley you would you would be it would be
destroyed and you would be fined and
when um Joseph strutty was the first guy
who really wrote about English Sports
and Past Times in George and England he
said when he moved to England he said
there are no Skittle alleys left in in
London there are no Skittle alleys left
in London
um although as it turned out they were
they were just they were kind of
underground Skittle alleys below Rave
culture in the 80s I think they must
have been organized like that
and look ahead to the Future then what
is the future going to be like for folk
Sports and our new folk Sports still
being invented
um I think that's sort of new as I say
new kind of eccentric things where and
people are playing quidditch and horse
ball and all these kind of things but I
think that the old Sports Still They
still hang on to kind of tenaciously
um and and really in recent years seem
to maybe maybe because of a greater
interest in craft beer and relay or
maybe as as help but certainly the coits
and sports like that are really a really
vibrant
well here's the future of shinty and
Skittles then thank you for joining me
Harry that's it for this week once again
thanks to kind of called genuity wealth
management for sponsoring the week in 60
minutes can Accord will provide you with
the expertise you need to help you build
your wealth with confidence visit can do
wealth.com for more information
thanks again for watching and do join us
again next week
[Music]
thank you